it's not turned
it doesn't matter which side you want to
go to because the spiral can be
generated from this angle
the spiral
you are going to yield
how far do you heal when he hits zero
okay so he hits zero
you have to reconcile
this one
this way
[Music]
different
not too young
uh
wow
uh so this this pattern is a
key
this pattern this pattern
this this is
the fight is inspiring
okay
it doesn't matter
he's here right you know
you see how i did that same time okay
so that's why i don't i don't really
care if you do it with multiple steps
you know
you don't have to be you know mr kamaya
okay
but
it's off to the back diagonal
okay
so here this way
it could be this way
you see
okay this matters
but again
it's not this
[Music]
you're fading into the spiral that's
that's the footwork you want that's the
the uh thai sabaki you want how do i
fade into the spiral
okay um
then the second one you have is
the question is how far do i pay
fake when he hits zero
okay so in other words i'm here
oh that's not zero
okay
so fade till he hits zero
just shy of zero do you understand
because you're gonna do the next phase
so as he's coming in
instead of shoving him back that way
he you're gonna do a kind of
a niche on his head
kodagash on his head
you get that
so don't go here
and boom here
you're gonna go here there's his head
and around
you see that
and that way he go he's
he's not going backwards yet you see
he's not going backwards but when i take
his head around then he's going
backwards
then i can enter because
he's going that way and i'm going with
him he goes that way he has a you know
if i if he's still going forward when i
enter this is a clash and you're just
trying to overpower someone he has to be
going the other way so
without the entry you see okay
so when i enter don't enter where he's
falling
so even though his head goes that way
i am not entering that one
you could i you could
but we're doing the x-patch
you see so
head goes one way
boom there it is
okay
let's go okay so the question is the
kodak on the neck okay well let's make
sure we understand further guys so
he's going in and i'm going to
[Music]
hey
right there right
right
right here
okay
do the same thing here
there
okay
so what i'm really doing is taking your
grip your contact grip
and making a new contact
here all right lay it
there it is
right there you see and then turn it
past your hand contact
to your head contact don't push here
okay yield
turn
not in front of your head and do it
i want you to touch your head
there it is
i touch that and i adhere on that
eyepiece on that
[Music]
different right
and here
okay
so in this version of this technique
she's she's loading the
i i'm not here going going
i'm not loading the 88 okay
so she's loading the edm
she loaded it
you see
if if when you watch me enter
it's to attack her base
it's not to throw her head
it's not to throw her head that's me
eddie that's me loading the adv do you
feel that so i'm here like this
so i can i can load these leave it out
what what you're mistaking with the
contact on her head is that is your arm
fear push response
is just stuck to her head
i just following her head you get that
that's not here and i go
it's following her head into the path
i just wiped your nose
she loves leaving me
i'm just staying here
i'm just staying with her
okay
and so you if you watch
boom
look at how much time this one takes
so yeah i have to be no patient
patience
patience means faith patience needs
faith because
patience means waiting
for the positive future outcome you want
okay
it doesn't mean patience
so waiting
if you watch you guys you don't want to
wait
you're like here and then you're like
that was enough
clearly i'm not shoving her head down
otherwise i couldn't get to the back of
it and hold it up
okay
it's just i'm maintaining contact
because that's where i was when i did
the
okay
you can ask like the big why why am i
here why why do this right
even like we do the body conditioning
and strength is important right
strength is important but if you pay
attention to what i said
it is important
for the training
so you can do the training
it's important in the fight that's true
but if you go well i'm here to learn how
to fight it's like really how many
fights do you how many fights have you
been in
zero zero what are you expecting the big
match tomorrow do you know
and those who got in a fight when's the
last time you got an actual fight
and what happens what do you what are
you imagining
you're 70 80
do you know what i mean
are you really gonna be
[Music]
the champ at 80
or maybe do you start going why am i
still such an [\h__\h] that i keep
getting in fights i'm 80 years old i
haven't [\h__\h] figured out how to
just get along with people
i mean these things what i mean is these
things cannot be your reason for being
here at this level
well you know i want to learn aikido why
why
you going to win the aikido olympics
you know there's not one
but here i think it's even crazier
because maybe you're like you know i
want to learn my keto so i can get some
rank and i can get some title and then
you know i can get people to start i can
charge them for seminars and i get the
seminar circuit going
yeah but we don't have that
that's not you're in the wrong place
we don't have that rank that title
there's just what we're doing what are
we doing and what is worth doing
it can't be
technical artistry it can't be
and it can't be martial prowess it can't
be these are temporary things
worldly things meaningless things
but reconciling fear
that's a real thing
we use it's a budo so we use
the training in martial arts
and here's the one the part you don't
like we use the training in martial arts
to generate fear
in you
so that you can reconcile fear
you can't work on
what you don't put on the work bench
do you understand
so we use that training
but the goal is not the martial arts
training
and so for that reason
it's wherever you're facing fear
that is the training
not the technique
or not just the technique
so sometimes it's
the uk is coming at you and you're
you're afraid you're afraid of failure
you're afraid of not getting it you're
afraid of how you're going to look to
people all that is [\h__\h] up well that's
why we're working on it
all that stuff leads to your suffering
and to the generation of your suffering
it just keeps going
you are out of alignment
you're broken
but you don't just break yourself you
start breaking everything you want to
break everything
so that then
we watch the fear in the ukemi
can you take the fall
do you pull out
do you decommit do you look for control
do you wish for a choreography
please let me throw myself
or can you just
reconcile fear
and let the natural force
the natural course way
do its thing
but sometimes fears and all kinds of
other things
you get a correction from your teacher
and it sends you in a loop
you don't like it
that's a fear
why should it send you in a loop
is it not possible just to receive the
correction input the information without
it going into this
childhood trauma
i don't
i don't feel good
i want you not to feel good
it is possible to receive a correction
purely
just like to receive the day and to
receive the sun coming up
undoubtedly there's people who dread the
sun coming up
but they're called vampires
they suck the blood of other people
they're the undead they're dead
hey you know you watch for for centuries
people in the way have looked at animals
and use them as
analogies i mean i never see my dog go
it's [\h__\h] monday
whatever it is is every day is friday
to my dog
do you understand
he doesn't dread the sun coming up or
the sun going down
he eats what food's there and if he
doesn't want to eat it he doesn't eat it
he does not go
[\h__\h] what crap is this [\h__\h] i'm eating
you [\h__\h] you hate me
he doesn't do it he just won't eat it
we're working on this technique work on
this technique get this correction
put that correction in
sometimes fear goes deeper than that
right because who cares if you get the
technique we only care about the
technique because of how fear ruins the
technique do you understand that that's
all we care about the technique
but in that same way it could be
a dojo etiquette
right
there's the on the dojo etiquette
there's a whole section and in that
section
it has
the golden rule
it reminds me of the law enforcement
policy or or the penal code
you you learn to read the code and
and it will say like
a a is against the law b is against the
law c is against the law
and then any other letter that you might
think of that i didn't write that's also
against this code it's like a catch-all
do you get it
well the golden rule is a catch-all
it's a catch-all in fear reconciliation
in how you
interrelate with other people
in other words you're not the same way
that ukeb resists
or the naga forces do you see those are
all fear responses the same way you
relate to other people you're it
technically
the technical word is ass wholly
you're not allowed to be an [\h__\h]
to anybody in this dojo
do you understand
you can't
curse at them
make faces adam
treat them in any other way
then i treat you
you can't do that you can't do that
you have to serve them
that's the same emptying of self
some of you i know for example
if one of you need help
and some of you would rather be in the
class than help them
do you see this
like if helping them conflicts with me
doing the class
i'm gonna i'm gonna not help i'm gonna
do the class
again what are you gonna be
you're gonna win the aikido olympics is
that even what we're working on
could you do that
could i could i say
will you do this
and you just do it could i give you a
correction and you just do the
correction
could i say will you help this person
and you just help them
or will do you have to go well then i
can't do my class
what's your class
do you get it what are you really
studying
but if i make you miss the class then
you feel robbed do you see
but where's the true teaching where is
the true teacher where is the trudeshi
is it really in the class
it's not in the class who gives a [\h__\h]
about the techniques
it's this fear reconciliation it is this
this forfeiting this capacity to forfeit
the self
can you do it
or is it always threatening to you
okay
sometimes you can do it
but i won't do it for you
i'll do it for you but i won't do it for
you
you outrank me so i'll do it for you
guys what the [\h__\h] where are you
what world are you in
i won't do it for you because
you're my husband
and you're not supposed to do this to me
you're not supposed to scare me
this is training
in the place where you're supposed to
reconcile fear
one i think he is supposed to scare you
here
and two i think the question is the same
question we've always asked hey
why don't you reconcile your fear why
don't you work on that
then at the same time
if you feel
there's no way she's going to reconcile
fear
not here this technique is terrifying to
her
don't
go too bad [\h__\h]
you're in the wrong place
time to get [\h__\h] up
no you know what you do you go this this
is not the partner
where i work on these things
these do you get that because you can
feel
the stirring up of
emotions you should be able to feel it
if you reconciled your fear you can tell
when it's stirring up
this is going to pull the wife card on
you
so you know we'll work on this
it's no different than when taylor's
working out with the newer the newest
destiny we have right now he's not
slamming you is he slamming you he's not
slamming you it was so gentle
it was like here's a pillow
tuck you in
and a pinky
[Laughter]
but he's yielding you see he's doing the
yield
he's doing the yin yield do you see the
yin yield into the spiraling geometry
this is an important geometry if you
watch the old films of both sensei
that's all he did this particular one
okay but
if you watch our films where we're doing
anything goes and the guy's punching and
kicking you're going to watch me do that
same yin yield into the spiraling
geometry do you see that because
the next thing the guy tries to do is
turn really sharp into where i'm at and
that takes them into the throes
you see that
so you just work on this do you see
if you watched on the video again i i
didn't i i have to teach
the reconciliation of fear to leah
because she's in the dojo you see
so i have to bring fear to the technique
the fear we're using here is
you're not in control
you see it's a great fear it's a primal
fear i'm not in control
fear of falling is another primal fear
okay
so i combined the two
you're coming forward do you see and you
you you no matter what you want you
somehow going to you are going to load
yourself on my hip
even though you don't want to look i
don't want to why am i on your hip
do you see that
right it's again going back to the
vampire it's like the woman that invites
the vampire into the house you're in the
audience you're like why'd you invite
the vampire in the house he could only
go in if you invite him
so i don't want to go on the hip [\h__\h]
him on the hip
do you see
that's enough to generate the fear that
now lets her practice on acceptance
release of ego
okay
but you've seen me lift and you've seen
me thrown ronin and taylor and this is
not was i chucking her no it was a very
very gentle throw do you see
so i'm not going hey
you're my dishy [\h__\h] off do you get it
this this is the place to work on food
right it's enough
do what you can
got it hey
but in this way it's very confusion
because you do what you can and you do
what you can
you don't say you don't do that because
i can't that's very woke
which is the opposite of confusion budo
has a confusion element to it you see so
you do
and you do
okay
but remember here remember
obviously to me fighting is important i
have a job i better know how to fight
right
but it can't it's not what's motivating
me
it can't motivate me
because even when i do the job what's
the whole point of the patrol strategy
not to get in a fight
do you see that
there's no way it's going to motivate me
here and there's no way uh technical
artistry is going to motivate me
right it's not it's not going to happen
our videos would be better produced
we would do seminars as citizens we
don't do seminars
if you want to come here you can come
here
and they wouldn't say such awful things
you can't say things people want to hear
this is very abrasive
very abrasive
this like this is very abrasive right
not a very friendly talk
but it's true
it's authentic
but remember why we're here we're not
here for these
for these worldly things fighting and
technical
mastery
that stuff's crap
okay but reconciling fear
that's gold
okay that's gold and remember
the dojo rule
value what should be valued
do not value what should not be valued
okay